ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
In the previous episode,
we realized that a Firebase
project is actually
a GCP project under the
hood, and that data that's
stored in Cloud Storage
can be equally accessed
via Firebase powered mobile
apps and web clients,
as well as from GCP
hosted applications.
In this episode, we'll
explore two more products--
Cloud Functions and
Cloud Firestore.
Stick around.
[THEME MUSIC]
Cloud Functions is really
a Google Cloud product
which also happens to be
visible from Firebase.
Cloud Functions is a
popular implementation
of the Functions as
a Service paradigm,
where an event in a
system, such as an HTTP
call or a file
uploaded to a bucket,
triggers the execution
of a small piece of code,
a function.
Check out the Serverless
Overview episode
for more details
on Cloud Functions.
An important
architectural difference
between the Firebase and GCP
approach to Cloud Functions
is that Firebase will offer
you to wrap your functions
into callable functions.
Such functions can be
invoked via the Firebase SDK
with user tokens and device
instance ideas propagated
directly to the function.
Another important difference is
the language that's supported.
When using Firestore,
Node.js and TypeScript
are supported, while Go,
Python, and Java are also
available when using GCP
Cloud Functions directly.
Before we compare web
consoles, you can also
use command line interfaces--
G Cloud or the Firebase CLI.
Both come with their own
set of functionalities,
and it's recommended to decide
which one works best for you
and stick to it.
To deploy functions
with Firebase,
you'll need to install Firebase
command line tools using NPM,
as deploying from the Firebase
console is not possible.
In GCP line, you
can deploy functions
straight from the
console, integrating
with GCP's private
source repositories,
or even typing the function
source code in line.
Firebase command line tools
do, however, come with an API
for strongly typed handling
of some trigger events,
and with the ability to deploy
multiple functions at once.
Just as you would
expect, a Cloud Function
created with a Firebase
project can also
be managed using Cloud Console.
In fact, clicking on Detailed
Usage Stats in Firebase
will take you to
that same function,
only in Cloud
Console, where you'll
get additional features, such
as monitoring graphs, a tab
to test the function,
and the ability
to set features such
as retry on failure,
memory allocation, or timeouts.
Whichever way you use Cloud
Functions in your Firebase
or GCP architecture,
they're likely to be
very effective at
what they do best--
small tasks in reaction
to all sorts of events.
Cloud Firestore is Google's
state of the art NoSQL document
database.
It is schema-less and offers
to store documents containing
attributes in a
hierarchy of collections.
It is fast.
It supports transactions.
It's highly available,
strongly consistent,
and it does not require managing
any kind of infrastructure.
Some will say it's a
serverless database.
Cloud Firestore comes
in two flavors--
datastore mode, which is mostly
suitable for server projects,
and native mode for
mobile and web apps.
Let me focus here on
the native mode, which
is the one that is common
to Firebase and GCP users.
This mode can
automatically scale
to millions of
concurrent clients,
but what makes it
even more special
is the fact that it offers
near real time notifications.
This is what enables
synchronization
of data across devices.
With its built-in
offline support,
you can access and make
changes to your data,
and those changes will
be sent to the cloud when
the client comes back online.
Data stored in
Cloud Firestore can
be accessed using Firebase
SDKs, and of course, you
can use either console to view
and edit data and indices,
and to monitor
database access usage.
With Cloud Firestore, you can
query the database directly
from your mobile or web
clients without the need
to set up an intermediary server
to manage access to your data,
and this is why the Firebase
console has an additional tab
for security access roles.
If you are a Firebase
user shipping
an app that accesses
Firestore, then you really
should use Firebase
Authentication
and think carefully about
your security access rules.
On the GCP side, there are
no equivalent security rules,
as you typically access
Firestore using a service
account.
Generally speaking,
server side code
is considered trusted,
as opposed to client code
from mobile apps.
Finally, supported Firestore
SDK languages include Python,
Node.js, Java, C#,
.NET, Go, PHP, and Ruby,
with Firebase mobile SDKs adding
web, Android, and iOS support.
These mobile Firebase
SDKs include local caching
as a unique feature
to help implement
the offline capability
that I mentioned earlier--
same project and
billing infrastructure,
common Cloud Storage,
Cloud Functions,
and Cloud Firestore services.
The two platforms
have a lot in common.
So whether you're
a GCP developer
interested in building mobile
and web apps with Firebase,
or a Firebase user trying
to grow your usage of GCP
services, you should now have a
good sense of what's possible.
It's time to get going with
Firebase or GCP or both.
Thanks for watching this video.
Please like, subscribe,
comment, share, and look forward
to more GCP Essentials videos.
[THEME MUSIC]